I believe it was a free and fair
election and that you lost well then
you're a fool however then you're a fool
maybe I am a fool Republican primary
voters deserve two things the truth
which they're not getting from Joe Biden
or Donald Trump and results on issues
they care about Donald Trump had a
chance to do that as president he didn't
why should we give him another I'm not
looking at what's going to help myself
or not I'm looking at speaking the truth
and I do think he was an excellent
president as judged by results but I'm
going to deliver something that he did
not National Unity this is the latest
thing involving President Biden where he
just said stuff which makes no sense
actually is pretty inappropriate it gets
personal and I don't want to be personal
about this I think it's kind of cheap
for me to go there I think I have a
chance of becoming the Democratic
nominee because my
numbers are better at beating
Republicans than
[Applause]
[Music]
him so what would you do right now in
Ukraine if you were the President Putin
uses the nword call it the nword he uses
the nword the nuclear word all the time
that's a no no you're not supposed to do
that he uses it on a daily basis and
everybody's so afraid so afraid so
afraid and as they're afraid he uses it
more and more that's why he's doing the
kind of things he's doing he's doing
them because he thinks nobody's going to
ever attack us because they're all
stupid and they're afraid to talk about
I totally agree with you okay so what
you do instead of excuse me it's a
little complicated sry instead of you
know cow Towing instead of
Biden saying oh he's got nuclear weapons
he keeps saying he's got we have better
weapons that we have the greatest
submarine power in history so what would
you say and do I would say we have far
more than you do far far more powerful
than you and you can't use that word
ever again you cannot use the nuclear
word ever again Harry is whipped do you
know the expression wh familiar with the
I won't use the full expression but
Harry is whipped like no person I think
I've ever seen I'm not a fan of Megan
yeah I'm not a fan and I wasn't right
from the beginning I think poor Harry is
being let around by his nose okay you
think it's going to end I do I've been a
very good predictor as you know I
predicted almost everything it'll end
and it'll end bad and I wonder if
Harry's going to go back on his hands
and knees and say please you know I I
think Harry has been LED down a path if
you were the queen is it at the stage
now would you remove that royal title I
would the only thing I disagree with the
queen on probably one of the only things
ever is that I think she should have
said if that's your choice fine but you
no longer have titles you no long and
frankly don't come around he has been so
disrespectful to the country and I think
he's an embarrassment the latest poll
says if a 2024 election was held
tomorrow you would beat Joe Biden by six
points and CA Harris by 11 points in
other words you would be reelected
president of the United States so are
you going to run again well well you
know for reasons of campaign finance and
everything I'm not allowed to say but
let me just say this I think a lot of
people are going to be very happy so you
I I love our country our country is
going to hell I think a lot of people
are going to be very happy so you're
going to run I'm not going to say that
but I think people are going to be happy
put another thing to you it's I've
because I've watched this whole debate
rage and you've been completely
unflagging in your refusal to accept
defeat you know why though you know why
because if our country doesn't have
fair and free elections and if our
country doesn't have borders we don't
have a country we have crooked corrupt
election here's what I would say to you
and I've proven it here's what I would
say to you I believe it was a free and
fair election and that you lost you
don't really believe that's my belief
well then you're a fool however then
you're a fool maybe I am the fool maybe
I'm the fool in in this conversation
about it you're a fool and you haven't
studied It Go great to see you good to
be back uh how's it going how you
feeling about running for president I
feel great you know been in for five
weeks um I feel really good I feel like
you know what I'm saying to people is
starting to break through in terms of
what we're seeing in the polling you
know we're at 9% now in New Hampshire
only four points behind Governor
DeSantis and for five weeks that's
pretty good so we're feeling good about
the way it's going and I will tell you
that um I'm enjoying myself and I think
it comes through the big elephant in the
room who's not here um Donald Trump way
ahead in the polls at the moment for the
Republican nomination how how you going
to knock him out directly there's no way
to do this like playing bumper pool
Pierce and I think that's the biggest uh
mistake that my adversaries in this race
are making they think somehow if they
you know maybe kind of in a sideways
looking way they say something negative
about Trump that people will get it and
then they'll go to them look there's one
lane to the Republican nomination in my
opinion and Donald Trump's at the head
of that lane and if you want to be the
man you got to beat the man and you got
to go bre through him and how do you do
that whilst not alienating the not
insignificant number of people in his
Maga base who blindly support Trump who
don't even care he's been indicted on
criminal charges they believe it's all a
stitch up because he's told them that
how do you manage to knock him out and
wipe him out of the race and keep those
people coming with you which you need to
win a general election well look first
off I think that the group that you'd
have to be worried about alienating is
relatively small compared to the entire
Republican primary and then in the
general election if you do knock him out
look those folks are going to look at
the choice between me and Joe Biden and
even if they feel some resentment
towards me from knocking out Donald
Trump they don't want 82-year-old Joe
Biden let alone 86y old Joe Biden in the
white house so and and I think when they
listen to me about the issues Piers you
know I want to send the National Guard
to the border to interdict fentanyl I'll
actually build the wall as opposed to
the 47 miles that Donald Trump built in
four years that's 12 miles a year he
needs like 40 years as president to be
able to finish the entire wall um he
said he was going to repeal and replace
Obamacare didn't get it done said he was
going to balance the budget he added Six
Trillion to the debt so Republican
primary voters deserve two things the
truth which they're not getting from Joe
Biden or Donald Trump and results on
issues they care about Donald Trump had
a chance to do that as president he
didn't why should we give him another
obviously when it started not many
people knew much about you other than
your entreprene oral stuff now since the
last debate uh you've become incredibly
well known very well talked about and a
lot of uh unfriendly fire is coming your
way so my first question is how are you
handling being now in the proper
Spotlight of being a presidential
candidate I'm fine with it and I do
think Pierce that's part of the process
we jumped into this race early on going
in Eyes Wide Open knowing that politics
is a dirty sport it's filled with
falsehoods you may have seen seen a
report over the weekend that actually
one of the other candidates large super
packs was taking credit to their donors
for the donors for the attacks that have
been manufactured against me that's okay
I can handle it and to tell you the
truth if I'm asking the people of this
country to ask me to represent the us
across the table from xiin ping I better
be able to sit across the table from
other candidates or from leftwing Media
or anybody else and so we're doing just
fine with it I'm focused on what we want
to achieve for this country shutting
down the administrative State keeping us
out of World War III declaring
independence from China growing the
economy Reviving national pride these
are my actual Focus areas not some side
attacks that could I really could care
less for okay look you've you've
certainly been so far I would argue the
most prot Trump of the other candidates
but that raises the question if he's so
great even to the extent you would
pardon him of any crimes he may be
convicted of why would you run against
him why not just let Donald Trump run
again and potentially win again and
maybe you get a a good job out of it in
other words if you keep talking him up
how does that help
you so the answer is I'm not looking at
what's going to help myself or not I'm
looking at speaking the truth and I do
think he was an excellent president as
judged by results but I'm going to
deliver something that he did not
National Unity uniting this country is a
top objective for me I'm 38 years old I
am the youngest person ever to run for
US president as a Republican and Piers
we're reaching the Next Generation in
droves we're Reviving national pride
amongst Young Americans 40% of my
100,000 plus donors our first time ever
donors to the Republican party in any
form that is unheard of that number is
normally 2% and so yes on 90% of policy
areas I do agree with Donald Trump and I
respect his accomplishments but there's
more to a president than just being a
policy book in a binder part of this is
how we reunite this nation I think I'll
be best position position to accomplish
that and I look forward to working with
Donald Trump when I hope he's my adviser
frankly my mentor in my first year in
office that much I will take but that's
how I think this is going to play out I
want to play you a clip this is
President Biden last week uh ending a
speech about gun violence by completely
randomly saying
this it's the least consequential part
of this whole meeting for you I promise
all right God Save the Queen
man okay well two things
the queen died 10 months ago we don't
She's Not Our Queen our mon yes it's not
your queen and and our queen died 10
months ago this is the latest thing
involving President Biden where he just
said stuff which makes no sense actually
is pretty inappropriate to some people
quite offensive he seems to forgotten
our queen died last year um and it goes
to his mental
capability it's a big issue I mean it
can't be ignored I don't think how do
you feel about this I you know I think
it's for the individual voter to decide
it gets personal and I don't want to be
personal about this I'm running against
the president on issues uh there are
many people in his Camp who would argue
yes he makes gaffs like this but when it
comes to his decision-making on issues
he's just fine every individual has to
decide on that and I think it's kind of
cheap for me to go there how concerned
are you never mind the race but how
concerned are you when you see President
Biden now in public the sheer volume of
missteps both verbal and physical does
it concern you as an American that the
president seems to be no I I don't
really think that I have
any uh additional wisdom to contribute
to that debate I I think that I don't I
haven't seen President Biden in a couple
of
years and I don't know you know I see I
saw him trip on the stage but you know
anybody can as you know anybody can trip
on a stage and uh and so I don't really
know what his condition is there are
worrying um you know videos and stuff
but I but you sense that he may not
actually run in 2024 when it comes to it
and is that why you think you actually
have a real chance of potentially
becoming the Democrat nominee I think I
have a chance of becoming the Democratic
nominee because my
numbers are better at beating
Republicans than him so and I think
that's what the Democrat could the party
make him stand as
for you well I you know that's first of
all that's not going to happen oh
doesn't that have to happen to let you
no no I mean I I have to win some
primaries and you think you can actually
beat him in I think I can beat him at
the primaries I mean it' be incredible I
mean pretty much unprecedent if you do
that right to an incumbent president
it's uh I I think I think Reagan did
that against uh Gerald Ford right oh but
um yeah I me it's unusual but you know
my father ran against incoming president
and he would have
won um and uh you know my Uncle Teddy
ran against Inc come at President Carter
and and lost do you actually he won uh
he won something like 37 states do you
actually believe that in 2024 when we
get to December January you will be the
person I on inauguration day addressing
the American people okay I'm going to be
very uh objective about this but I'm
telling you that we have a few seconds
left if I had put money and bet on any
candidate I would put it on
[Applause]
[Music]
me